good morning everybody as you have heard
I'm working for this lovely company
called trivago and by the number of ads
that I saw on the way here I think you
probably know it but I've not always
worked there I've worked in the games
industry before like quite a long time
and I did something that we call back
then parallel programming and when I
started working go I was a little bit
confused because suddenly everybody was
talking about concurrency and it was
like yeah it's probably the same thing I
turn now that concurrency is not the
same as parallel programming or
parallelism because parallelism is about
parallel execution and concurrency is a
little bit more because concurrency is
about design it's about designing your
program as a collection of independent
processes it's about designing these
processes to eventually run in parallel
they don't have to but they can and last
but not least it's about writing your
code so that the outcome is always the
same regardless if you run it in
parallel or sequential now this is a
rather top-level view of concurrency so
let's get a little bit more into detail
this means that if you have your code
base or you have your set of problems
and you're actively looking for little
tasks that you can group and you will
run these tags alongside each other
maybe sequentially or parallel but this
grouping is quite important and it means
that your code shouldn't have any race
conditions because race conditions by
the very nature produce an unpredictable
outcome so there is definitely a change
and almost the same is true for
deadlocks because if you have got a
deadlock then you have got no outcome at
all so it definitely doesn't work and
last but not least concurrency is also
about scale so you want to run faster
when you get more workers you certainly
don't want to get slower but this can
sometimes happens if you have a bad
concurrency model and speaking of a
concurrency model we're here for a go
conference so how does go tagger
concurrency well goat choses quite
interesting model and this model is
called communicating
processes or CSP in short and CSP is
nothing new it's been around since the
1970s and it's been used in a couple of
languages so Oakham Erlang so many
languages use it but the beauty about
CSP is that is so very very simple
it follows only three distinct rules and
the first one is already pretty awesome
because it says you just write your
little processes as sequential code and
this is nice because we all write
sequential code we did this for decades
we're really good at that and if you've
ever done writing parallel code in other
languages you know that there's a fair
amount of brain power going into that
because it's quite complicated to do so
and CSP says yeah forget about that just
do sequential code it's nice and the
next part is quite interesting because
it's a thing the backbone of CSP and it
says that every one of your processes
has a local state and it only operates
on that local state you don't have
shared state
no sharing at all and if you don't have
sharing you don't have deadlocks you
don't have race conditions and if you
have to transfer data from run process
to the other you don't share it you
communicate it you send it over you send
a copy over from your process to the
other process so that every process can
work independently and if you follow
these two steps and scaling is quite
easy so because you scare about just
adding more of the same so you have this
process with this very fancy calculation
that takes some time yeah pull up to new
go routines next to it it just works
well that's nice so what is go give us
to work with concurrency and especially
to work with CSP and well there are four
tools essentially the first one is go
routines but I won't talk about go genes
today because this is essentially
talking on its own because it's quite
complicated I would talk more about
channels because they had the backbone
of CSP and if we're talking about
channels we also have to talk about
selects because this is how you manage
channels and last but not least there's
this fourth
it's a sin package and if you look at
the same package
it doesn't sound all like CSP there's
all this classic stuff and they're like
Mooji sees condition variables it's so
why is this even here I mean do we
really need that oh you see later so but
let's first talk about channels and to
get you all under the same roof let me
explain how they work in this section
essentially when they were block so I
like to see channels as a kind of bucket
chain you know the thing from the
medieval times where you had like the
well of water on one side the burning
building on the other side and then the
chain of little Gophers passing along
buckets eventually pushchair putting out
the fire it's like that yeah and in this
bucket chain you have like three
components you have the sender like the
go for pulling off the water you have
the receiver the go for tossing the
water into the building and you have all
these little Goofy's in between and
actually you don't really need them so
you just need the sender and the
receiver and there's pretty much how
channels work so you can just get rid of
the buffer you can add it or you don't
need it so they are buffered and
unbuffered channels and go okay and if
we have this picture in mind it's easy
to see when channels start blocking and
the first case happens when this gopher
is putting the bucket out of the wall
and but there's no one to take it so
there's no receiver are they just busier
is simply not there so you stand there
we should bucket in hand and you're
waiting for someone to take it or in
other words you block and this doesn't
really change if you have a queue up go
for us in between you and the sender
because you can pass on the bucket to
the next go friend a chain but at some
points all Gophers are holding buckets
and then it doesn't get on so you're
blocking or the sender sides is a little
simpler because there's just one rule no
data means blocking and this doesn't
change if you have forget a buffer
before you or not
if there's the data you stop working in
you're waiting for new wet data okay
this is all rather funny to look at but
let's have a look at some codes so let's
create an unbuffered channel so no go in
betweens just send and receiver and
first we want to get some
thing from the channel what happens well
of course we block because there is no
data no data always means blocking okay
away with that so we try to send
something through the channel what
happens well it blocks yes because there
is no one taking the bucket from you so
I'm standing there waiting for someone
to take my buckets so I have to block
okay okay we got it so we need a send
and a receiver so we should start a
receiver when one go routine and then
send this is this block well a little
bit because it blocks until both
functions reach the Senate channel
operation so it's essentially some kind
of synchronization pattern and it is
what you see something in code basis so
they use this to synchronize to go
routines to just continue at a certain
point though you can use it like that
okay how does it change when you add a
buffer well now we have one gopher in
between should be enough and we try to
receive something from the channel again
what happens it's blocking yes of course
it blocks because there is no data and
if we send something to this channel
well this time we're fine because there
is a gopher that can take our bucket and
if we send again what happens we block
again because all the Gophers are
holding packets okay so why am i
stressing that so much why is blocking
so important well because blocking
breaks concurrency because if you block
you can have dead logs and yes you can
build that locks with channels you can
do that and we certainly wanted to avoid
that locks and we and blocking can also
lead to scaling knock work properly like
imagine you have like one receiver and
the only one and you have none buffer
channel in front now regardless of how
many senders you put in there only one
send at the time will work so what do
you create by adding more senders you
just create more overhead so essentially
in the best case you just at the same
speed with the same amount of workers
but you will eventually get slow at some
point so you don't want to have that
okay so but before we see how to fix
that
let's look at another nice property of
channels and that is closing
and it's not that complicated as most
people think it is because you have to
wear my man one thing closing always
generates a message and that's the first
thing and this message is something like
a little sign saying okay there will be
no more data and this sign will just
bubble through the whole chain and at
the end the receiver will see it and say
hey yeah no more data got nothing to do
and just immediately go off it doesn't
really look at this even it will just
leave the message and just go on play
something and now if you imagine that
now it becomes apparent what happens
when you send something to this channel
that is closed your go routine will
panic and why will it panic because
you're standing there with your bucket
in hand and no one will ever take it
from you so your data is lost of course
you panic another thing as closing
always generates message closing twice
also panics now you know why okay but
how does this look like in code so let's
create a channel and unbuffered one or
buffer one doesn't matter because we
immediately close it and then we receive
which we can because closing always
generates a message so what gets printed
zero a good thing yeah so if something
has to be printed and actually there two
values printed it's zero and four so why
the hell is there two values well the
first one is this closing message and
this is always the zero value of the
type of your channel so in this case
it's integer so it's zero yes correct if
you have a pointer then it's no and so
on and the second parameter is always
there we just tend to ignore it and this
parameter is true for every case but for
the last message so you can see either
as a valid boolean so the last message
is not valid or you can see it as a more
boolean saying there is no more data
coming through but you can always carry
that and by that you can see if the
channel is closed and now you see the
receiver always knows if the channel is
closed but the sender never does if the
sender sends then the only thing you can
do is panic and that is why you normally
only close the channel from
sending site never found the receiving
side okay so with channels and clothes
and all these buffered things you get
along quite well I see you will be great
programs with that but you will just
ceiling at some point and that normally
happens when you have more than one
channel and in that point you need
something else you need select and
select a something like a switch
statement over your channels and it
really works the same way so you have
selected at the beginning and then you
have a couple of cases you even have a
default case and each case has a channel
operation so either send or receive or
you can even mix both and the rule is
the first operation that is non-blocking
will be chosen and if all the cases are
blocking then the four case will be
chosen alright and that's interesting
because if the default case is always
chosen we can do a nifty thing we can
create and unblock a non-blocking
channel we can write a function like
this we call it try receive and we
select door of a channel and if the
channel that contains data will turn it
immediately but if the channel blocks
let me get to the default case and then
we can return hey this channel would be
blocking so but we directly continue so
we get around the blocking problem and
you also see that sometimes in some code
bases but there's a promise that because
this is a tad unrealistic because
normally you have channels with a
certain kind of throughput so you have
like is solve messages per second or
something so you know that for a certain
time frame
there will be no message and you want to
wait for the next message to come so we
can do that too by just altering this
example a little bit and we can use a
function from the time package for that
and this function is time after and time
offer is interesting because it returns
a channel yes of course you can return a
channel why not
and this channel will be blocking
immediately and it will be blocking
until the duration is over and when it
is over it was sent the time when the
channel was unblocked so by doing this
we now have a
Seve with a timeout which is a lot more
realistic in cases where you have a
certain throughput okay so but doing
tricks like that is not the true power
of select because select can do more and
this becomes apparent if you see your
channels as streams of data because if
you do it like that you can see that
select is more about routing your data
along so you can define different
routing patterns you can have something
like a fan-out wave like one stream of
data coming in and multiple one coming
out or you join multiple streams into
one but it would then be a funnel or you
can just do mix and match between
different streams and this is a turn out
okay and to illustrate that let's have a
look at the easiest example which is a
fan-out and this is just it the first
thing that you do is you range over the
channel and yes you can do that and if
you do you will receive data all the
time until the channel is closed and if
it is closed then the loop will
discontinue and you won't process this
last message so it works exactly like
you would just like it to behave
okay so we're now receiving data and we
have it and now we can send it to one of
these two channels and that's where you
select we send it to the first channel
that has placed a waiver so that can
draw data so it's a little bit like a
load balancer that we just created and
it's very useful if you have a set of
workers and you want to choose the first
wake a worker which is a Weibull and for
that it's great okay this is very simple
so let's make it a little bit more
complicated and turn this into a turnout
and the first thing that we have to do
is to have get rid of their range
because now we have to get data from two
channels and again we can do this we
select because select works and sending
and receiving so we receive data from
the first channel that has data and then
at the end we'll pass it over like with
it which the fan out into the first
channel that has space available so
quite simple but there is an interesting
thing in that and this is the part in
the middle the where do we actually stop
here
because they're just thinking about
select if you have a closed channel in
there it tends to be chosen all the time
so if you close one channel you will
always get to that case and you'll never
get to the other channel which might
still have data so this doesn't really
work and you can't really remove a case
from the Select case not easily let's
say like that so you have to think of
something else and one way how you can
do it is to use a so-called quit channel
and this is how it works so you add that
adds an additional channel and the only
reason for this channel to exist is to
be closed you don't pass any data around
you just close it and as you do you then
close the two incoming channels yeah but
now you say oh but wait a minute this is
an anti-pattern because we just said
before that the receiver should never
close yes essentially it is but in that
case it's okay because you say the
sender says quit and this is just a
delegate to close the other two so it's
a little bit around but it's okay so
once we have closed the channels we can
drain them and we can use the parent
that we saw before because this is just
the same fan-out that were used so
selecting channels are quite powerful
and you can do and tremendous amount of
work with that I I guess like 90% of
your use cases can be covered with CSP
channels and select but sadly they are
these remaining 10% and so where do
channels fail well first off channels
can still block where we can make them
all unblocking but it's not desirable
because sometimes we want channels to
wait oh we want operations to wait and
if we do then we have the same problems
as before
the next thing is channels pass around
copies because remember about the local
state so you have to pass a copy so that
the local state stays local and if you
do that with for example a two gigabyte
Photoshop file that is probably not a
good idea because it takes a fair amount
of processing power and if you now say
well it just lets pass a pointer
well that is somewhat erased conditions
through the backdoor because no one
prevents the sending go routine from
holding the same point
modifying it afterwards and that's
actually one of the nasty bugs that we
had in Gollum it's exactly that so
please don't do that took quite some
time to get rid of that and last but not
least there are these naturally shared
structures like caches well yes you can
build a cache with a channel in front
but no please don't him it's really ugly
and it doesn't really make sense because
caches are about sharing so you have
some structures in each sharing so what
do we do yeah well you remember from the
one of the first slides it's in package
yeah that is what you do you choose
something like a mutex for example well
but there's a problem because mutti sees
are a little bit like toilets like no
longer you occupy them the longer the
queue in front gets so you don't really
solve the problem you just shift it to
somewhere else and this is even a little
bit worse than we have this channel say
not that good so you can mitigate this
problem by using a readwrite lock
because there the reads will be parallel
always and just the writes are blocking
but then again this only mitigates the
problem and it only works in situations
where you have a lot more reach than
writes and in the end if you start to
use mutex at some point you will have
more than one and if you have you will
get into trouble because someone will
always mess up the order if it's not you
it's someone else trust me I've been
there
so using multiple mutexes is also not
quite nice so all in long a working
solution but not really the one we're
looking for so what else can we do and
now it has to look a little bit back to
the time we're just at parallel
programming because there we defined
like three sites of code and there you
have it you have blocking code and this
is what we saw this is code that can at
some point just log up it doesn't mean
it has to but it can so you have no
guarantee that it does not and every
time you have something like a mutex in
between then you have blocking code lock
free code and the contrast gives the
guarantee that at least one
part of your program is making progress
and that is least something and then we
have it somewhat that is the Holy Grail
and that is weight free programming but
as the same with the Holy Grail it's
very hard to achieve that so we have to
have a fair amount of brainpower to get
there and just that is a side note so if
you think that going down this list
equals faster no it is not so we saw
blocking code how do you write lock-free
code or weight free code well turns out
there is another package in the sync
package and it is sync atomic and there
is only these little set of functions in
there and this is storing loads the
certain gaps this is add or subtract if
you use negative values this is swap
simple exchange and this fancy function
called compare and swap which is swap
but they will leave a certain
preconditioners matter and the cool
thing about these function is that they
are thread safe by design actually they
are CPU instructions so your CPU cares
about that this works and you don't need
new T sees for that they just work just
work means they're just a little bit
slower just ten times but let's be
honest like that takes half a cycle so
we're talking about like something like
5 to 30 cycles which is still quite fast
you should just not litter them all over
your code because that would be bad um
but the problem about atomic operations
is yes there are only that's few
operations this sounds a lot like easy
to learn but hard to master and that is
really the case so there are a lot of
edge cases and most people are afraid of
you think that are for reason but I just
want to give you some patterns at hand
so that you can use them and maybe start
programming luckless and the first
pattern I want to show you is the
so-called spinning compare-and-swap and
this is a very very basic pattern and
you see that like all over the place and
it's quite simple you just need two
things you need a variable which is our
state and you need a constant which is
called free in this case and now you
start spinning and you use these CAS or
compare-and-swap operation so you see if
your stay
equals the free value and if it does you
immediately change it to something else
and now the cool thing as this is an
atomic operation at the moment you were
able to change this value you were
definitely the only one doing this so
everybody else is still spinning and
you're the only one who's not and
everybody's still spinning until you set
it to free again does it sound familiar
somehow
sounds a lot like a LOX doesn't it well
actually it is and if you look at the
implementation of the sync mutex it's
using exactly that pattern and to
illustrate that it's this so this is the
most basic lock that you can do this how
many lines of code is that three four
yeah okay so what do we have we have the
state then we have our free constant
which happens to be zero because I like
that and when we lock we compare and
swap over this state and try to look for
free and if it's really set it to 42 and
if it's not free we just continue we
didn't do anything and there's this
other thing which is run time go
schedule and I just promised not to talk
about goat cheese but here I have to if
you have such a tight loop blue please
always use run time go scheduled because
otherwise your program will lock up in a
singer' threaded case so if you have
only one CPU this will log up a lot of
fun and go one point for where this was
it afford him so you can use that if you
have more functions in between you don't
need that it's just if you don't have
any functions there it's a simple
explanation there's more beyond that ok
so once we have our lock we can do some
things and when it can unlock it again
so the cool thing about this pattern is
that you now have the choice to do
something in the case where normal mutex
would have locked so you can do
operations there you can do whatever you
want you can maybe switch to something
else or load a file or whatever but you
certainly don't need to block you can do
other things ok but this is a rather
simple thing and to take this a little
bit more complex or make it a little bit
more useful even let's have a look
another pattern that actually uses this
pattern in between and this is called
the tickets
rich and this is now a little bit more
complicated now we have three things we
have an index data structure so for
example a slice we have a ticket
variable and we have had done variable
and when you want to add something to
our storage then the first thing that we
do is we draw a new ticket so we add one
to our tickets variable and as this
function is atomic you can be sure that
you are the only one who got that number
nobody else will okay until in 64 over
fluids but this takes some time so now
so we now have an index that only we own
we can use that to store data so nobody
else will store data at that index so we
don't have any race conditions there and
that is nice because we can just go
ahead and when we're done we increment
the done counter so that we know where
the data is written because the write
itself is not atomic okay so let's have
a look at some code so this is a little
bit more clear so here we have it we
have to take it variable we have the
done variable and we have our slots
which for simplicity reason is now a
slice and normally you would have
something like a reading buffer here and
if we do a put the first thing is we do
an atomic at and we have to subtract
meaning a minus one because we get the
value after their operation and as soon
as we did that we can be sure that
nobody at our slots will write so we can
do that and then we increment it by
using what we already saw now this looks
a little weird but let me get it to that
the more interesting part is they get
done function because this function is
essentially weight free it will always
immediately return the whole portion of
your slice that is done that is written
it will return it will not block it will
just always work and this is pretty nice
now let's talk about this thing here
because this block is essentially
keeping us from being weight free in
this function so why is it in there why
do we need to do that well yeah we can
try out so let's do some debugging
so for debugging atomic code I use a
little game called the instruction
pointer game and what you do is you take
your code pull up two windows air same
code in both windows and they have one
instruction pointer and this instruction
pointer may move through both windows
but it can only be in one window at a
time and the rule is you can switch at
any instruction and by instruction I
mean assembly instruction so if you see
plus equals this are actually two
instructions
so have fun jumping in between the plus
and the equal so if you do that then you
watch your code and your variables and
see if you have the right condition
doing that just what we're now going to
do so we replace the loop with a simple
add and play the instruction pointer
game so we start on the left and we get
our tickets so we get the ticket number
one and now we jump over because we can
and we get another ticket which is two
because yeah well we always get this new
ticket and nobody else will have it
let's just go on say yeah we write to
our slot everything fine but then we
increment the done and then we're saying
Oh index number one is done but index
number one is not done we have not
written to it yet
so this is our array so we have a race
condition year and that is the reason
why we have this loop this loop will
essentially wait until the done variable
is at the state of our tickets so we can
increase it so it will have an ordered
release so to say okay so these are new
two examples of how you can do atomic
code and you could probably come up with
some more patterns but as we're running
out of time let's just give you a few
guides for writing atomic code the first
one is if you use an atomic variable or
use atomic functions on a variable just
always use atomic functions on Intel
this doesn't hurt you that much another
platform it does
why does well there are some excellent
talks by herbs that are like two hours
or something like that and he will
explain that so I won't do that now but
trust me just do it it you will have
some weird side effects if you don't
and if you got that managed then look
for situations where you have uniqueness
like for example this you were the only
one who could have changed that variable
you are the only one who got that number
and if you have the situations then
exploit it try to do something with that
and one thing though avoid changing two
things at a time because this is super
hard you can do it like with bit
operations so for example having two
32-bit values in one 64-bit integer but
every time I show these code to my
colleagues they just hate me for that
because they don't understand it
and someone still trusts don't just
trust me that this actually works okay I
hope it is the other one is you can try
to do ordering of your operations but
this is really hard because sometimes
it's not possible and sometimes you
forget one specific case so not that
easy good so now we've seen quite a fair
lots of things so we have seen channels
we've seen CSP we've seen atomic code so
where does it all fit it in their
overall picture of concurrency the first
thing that you should think of when
doing concurrency is avoid blocking and
avoid race conditions this is the most
essential thing and the easiest way to
do that is by using CSP because they you
don't have shared state and shared state
is number one reason for race conditions
and for locking so if you don't have
this you're fine and really 90% of the
cases can be done with these people ease
use it and if you have one of these rare
cases where doesn't work then first
thing you should do use the sync package
use a mutex because it's simple
people will understand it and it's
proven and if you have something that
does still not work or you have a very
simple case like just incrementing an
integer for a counter then use atomic
operations or if you want to have some
fun grow up your favorite data structure
and try to implement it lock less and
then you will see how hard it can be to
write a linked list and by that I want
to close the talk thank you for
listening
thank you are any questions
nothing oh you got to give him a minute
no questions all right let's give honor
a big one applause thank you
[Applause]